how many film festivals did you submit
to we've submitted to 14 film festivals
and so far we've gotten into the ones
that we've submitted to and that's what
we're going to do for the next six
months is just I'm going to tour with it
and go to theaters and not only do
festivals but also do some independent
theaters and get it into some smaller
towns where I feel like people really
need to see it not just in big cities so
I'm kind of doing what the what the
musicians do I'm going on tour I'm
taking my baby and I'm like putting the
print on my back and like walking in and
like connecting with people and doing it
like old-school style totally so of
those 14 that you submitted to what was
like criteria what kind of research did
you do or just from being in the
business you knew these were the ones i
think from being in the business I just
knew what festivals I had a lot of
respect for I knew what festivals I
wanted to avoid because it's mostly just
about who's in your movie and how big
your budget is and I'm just so not into
that so I'm really happy that we
premiered at dances with films because
they're just they're just purposely
independent and I always happen so they
don't do a red carpet they do a green
carpet it was just perfect for me so
it's lining up perfectly like all the
festivals that I'm doing I'm just really
happy to be a part of them for other
filmmakers what should they look for
when they target a film festival should
they look for that sort of the perfect
audience fit with their movie I mean if
they're doing some type of a documentary
about people in Nairobi should they
really try for some of these more
glitzier festivals or what sort of
something they should do behind the
scenes to make sure it's worth
submitting for their film I think you
have to be very selective when you've
made a film because it can get very
expensive like submitting to festivals
on all your press materials all your
entry fees I think you need to use your
intuition and not just go for what you
think is the glamorous festival because
those don't necessarily get you the most
attention or the most press which is
what you need for your film you know
lots of times these bigger festivals
it's about what name is in your film and
who's who's battling to to purchase it
and you know you just want to you want
to pick festivals that relate to your
subject matter and if it's a festival
that's known for documentaries then go
for that if it's a festival known for
you know dramatic features like just do
a lot of research read a lot of books I
think research is key
you